one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast Happy First Tuesday in
May it is Jackson Claude back in studio
in the New York headquarters toasty
Vibes with new buccal chairs that's
right if you're watching on YouTube
we've had a little bit of a facelift now
that Jax is here thought we'd you know
I thought we'd step things up a bit well
we've been meaning to get the second
buccal chair and it came just in time
for this week which is perfect and I'm
feeling really good about it you're
feeling good I know people are going to
let us know how they're feeling about it
yeah but I feel good about it for a few
reasons one it's more comfortable to sit
in you're not like folded on top of
yourself yes
um I think it looks really nice I think
so too and because I like it and need
you say more no no we've got a great
show it has been a minute so the last
you heard from us yesterday we had
living jacks on the Pod podcast only
hope you guys enjoyed Friday we had
Shannon Thursday we had Sophia it has
been me
Jackie Wednesday we had Sophia Tuesday
we had Taylor I don't remember but it's
been a whirlwind couple of weeks thanks
for sticking with us through my journey
to Stagecoach Jax's brief sabbatical
we're back and better than ever oh yeah
how are you doing Mrs Stagecoach 2023
I'm not okay I don't think anyone
thought that you were okay because we're
seeing you when you're having fun but we
know our turd and it's like this is
taking everything from her is it not
with the fun giveth the fun taketh away
yeah I can't believe I am standing up
straight right now I flew home yesterday
from La I was literally on like a
72-hour Bender in Stagecoach it was so
much fun I haven't been to Stagecoach
since
I think it's been four or five years
because it was pre-covered and then we
missed one the one before Kobe because
we were on a trip we went to 2019. oh my
God I forgot how laborious it is on your
body like it was record high
temperatures 106 degrees like not okay
so much walking so much drinking and so
much hanging out with girls younger and
fitter than me and I really like I
couldn't keep up
you looked like you were keeping up
that's you know that's what I do I put
out like false pretenses about my life
but I was not keeping up in any way
shape or form and my body was like not
my own this weekend I was dealing with a
bunch of
um a bunch of ailments ailments yes I
spoke on the podcast on Friday about how
I made the mistake of taking a z-pack on
an empty stomach on Thursday so Thursday
I was completely out of commission
Friday I felt better but I was still
recovering from the Thursday Saturday I
got hit with I don't know something else
at the festival I was just I mean I was
just like drinking all day like we'd
forgotten to eat there was like so it's
not really a mystery yeah I know there
were 16 lines for food like we just
couldn't so each coach actually did a
really good job of making sure everybody
had water they were giving out free
premium bottles of water it was actually
really like I was doing good with the
water we just for kept forgetting to eat
because it was like okay we'll go here
and then we'll have something to eat but
it was just hard to find food so
Saturday I was not okay and Sunday I was
not okay either so I had the best time
it was amazing I am so glad I went and
I'm so glad it's over like it was just a
lot but I had the best time I loved the
way my outfits turned out and if you
watch the Vlog on patreon of me like
trying to put together my outfits for a
stagecoach you know it was not an easy
task like I was struggling till the very
last minute like I was putting together
outfits in Palm Springs you were yeah it
felt like you were in a good place when
you left I was in a decent place when I
left and for
um most of my outfits like I had the
basics I didn't bring the right
accessories I did not bring the right
shoes I did not bring the right bags but
I worked through and you know everyone's
chairs everyone was really generous the
great thing about traveling with Shannon
is she travels with a Armory of studying
beautiful and high-class designer pieces
that
she is more than happy to take off of
her neck and give to you she's so
generous like couldn't be me you know
like I have fabulous things if I'm not
wearing it I'll think about letting you
wear it but hers like no like it would
be better on you like so generous it was
it was really nice to see someone so
fabulous and so generous with their
things it's an inspiration to us all
it's an inspiration to everyone every
not there was not one day that went by
that at least somebody did not borrow
something from Shannon that's so nice
whether it was like a core piece like a
stunning blouse or just like a necklace
you know she was so generous it was so
amazing well you guys all looked great
we all loved following along I'm sure
you listened to my episode with Olivia
yesterday where we were
um it was very flattering just sort of
like lauding you guys for all your style
and creativity and uniqueness and verb
and I feel really good about the fact
like we and I made such good content
like I was with the pictures and the
tick tocks like I did a good job and it
looked like I was having so much fun and
I really was like it was like I had the
best time even though the lineup was
like
it was okay it was okay
um it actually like wasn't even great
but the music was so good and I have to
just give like such a shout out to Old
Dominion they were
they weren't even a headliner they were
incredible like they totally could have
had lined I really forget like how many
just bangers they have and everybody
knows I mean country loves them and they
did a Harry Styles cover which was so
unexpected but so good and the lead
singer was literally on crutches but
like you wouldn't have known it they
were amazing Chris Stapleton was a Vibe
I mean it was a little sleepy oh really
it was a little sleepy and you know him
it's like oh I have a four minute song
let's make it eight and add you know a
whole bass solo and it was like a little
like okay yeah you want to hear from our
basis yeah right it was like okay nobody
it was like oh let me play the bass oh
okay it was it was a little better
because you know that part in the show
where they introduced the band it's it's
nice
it's nice but it's a do we care no no
but I understand why it's important for
the band members to be seen and
recognized no and it's also like you
know the the leads like the the star
doesn't want to be like hey it's all
about me this star is like pretending
star doesn't want to say hey look at me
right the Stars pretending to be like
you know humble and gracious but it's
like we don't care
um I know that's mean to say like we
don't
um and then they tell you where they're
from and like how long they've been with
the bed and then they do like a little
thing it's like save it for the
documentary okay yeah we don't care
um but actually Chris Stapleton didn't
do that
did other people do that no actually oh
good no so the headliners were Luke
Bryan who I've seen headline before and
he really puts on a great show and he's
like a great performer but it's like
it's not like the most amazing music
like it's good you know no when he he
headlined when we went in 2019 and we
were all really surprised with how much
we enjoyed ourselves yeah it was good it
was a show it was entertaining Kane
Brown
um was was good he also has like a lot
of songs that um you forget that you
know and then he brought his wife out
which was really sweet I think she was
so [__] nervous like there was like
literally 80 000 people there but he
didn't bring out like any special guests
except for his wife which was really
sweet and then Chris Stapleton the third
day so like honestly the headliners
weren't like next level crazy but they
were all the thing with country music is
like everybody can sing yeah and
everybody can play the guitar and they
put on a show and it says they got the
fireworks it was great but so many of
the smaller Acts were like so amazing
too like Gabby Barrett Margaret was like
we have to get there early for Gabby
Barrett I'm like shut up like the thing
about Margo she's like I have to be the
first one there and the last one out
like by the end we you were like Margo
please let us go home she was like
literally being like Stalin of
Stagecoach but I'm glad we went because
Gabby Barrett like was that [__] Gabby
bear was that [__] we also went early
another day for Elle King one of the
best sets I've seen like she and by the
way she like
she wanted to hang you know she had DM
me she was like she was like you want to
hang and I was like yeah I'd love to
hang so we like were drinking with her
before the show we met her son oh my God
he's so [__] cute how old is he
I can never tell these kids he was
either 2 or 17 like I'm not sure but
like I'm gonna say
I honestly four okay okay no honestly I
don't know four is confusing maybe three
honestly I don't know okay but I like
like Kayla a little bit bigger thing
actually no I was giving
I don't know I was giving Kayla energy
but like I don't know all kids give
Kayla energy because they're just kids
um but I finally got to tell Elle King
that she and I both went on Say Yes to
the Dress and chose the same exact dress
and she was like oh my God no way and I
was like yeah but I didn't wear it
because like it was ugly she's like yeah
I didn't wear it either because I didn't
get married oh my God she was so cool I
never met her before um she was so fun
and really like she put on a show she
did like her big hits and you really
forget like how many and she she there's
like this Tyler Childers song that
everybody's obsessed with that is
unreleased and it's like we all know the
song but we don't know how because he's
never released it and I guess he gave
her permission to release it so she did
her own coverage it's like her song now
so people were like creaming their pants
like it was like oh my God Tyler
Childers and then something weird
happened with Tyler Childers so do you
know about Tyler Childers a little bit
he's like this folksy type of singer
he's like he's country but he's really
like deep blue grass not you know not
real country you know like people like
that they like love Tyler Childers you
know he's real yeah yeah yeah and he was
playing Stagecoach and Stagecoach is
very much like a mainstream country
Festival it's like pop Radio country so
it was really kind of crazy and he was
at the Palomino tent which isn't the
main stage it's um it's a long walk and
it's you know it's for smaller artists
and it was kind of weird that he was
there um but I figured you know he's a
little bit more Indie maybe not everyone
knows him oh my God we could not even
walk in it was so crazy and it's a tent
so if you're outside the tent you can't
[__] see anything yeah and it felt
like like weird and disrespectful to
Tyler Childers and everyone was like
literally standing around being like
what is this like it was so weird we
honestly we stayed for a few songs but
we couldn't see and we couldn't hear
we're like okay this is boring
um but it was like he honestly like he
could have headlined right maybe they
just miscalculated his popularity maybe
because his popularity very Niche and
they probably go by like radio numbers
and all these like classic mainstream
and he doesn't tricks and he's not that
guy he doesn't play that game like he
doesn't do the radio tours like he just
puts out his music he doesn't even like
post on social media you're right
there's no way to measure but it was
weird because like he was seven o'clock
at the Palomino stage and then seven
o'clock on the main stage was Cameron
Marlow is that his name yeah
um who cares and it's like he's just
someone who plays the game radio tour
does the festival and it's just like
okay I'm gonna chalk it up to a
miscalculation I don't want to think
that they were like sliding citing him
okay no it was just like drama at the
festival we were like starting and I
think that's like cool that he bust out
of the gym yeah we were starting stuff
like and we're like can you believe this
and everything I feel like that happens
a lot of times at festivals like someone
is a smaller artist and they just bring
a much bigger crowd than you would
expect no like the one year that we saw
um that we were at Coachella and Billy
eilish was there but before she was like
major yeah she was at the Palomino but
it's called something else over there
um and everyone was like can you believe
and like we didn't even go because we're
like who cares yeah we didn't but then
like two years later she was a headliner
right yeah no you're right it was a
miscalculation for sure yeah
um it's just the best weekend like I ran
into so many toasters which was just the
best because toasters are so country and
honestly I was literally a zombie I was
like I was running on like no sleep no
food and just like so much alcohol and I
was like yeah everyone was like the way
turdy Lou has taken on
and I was just like I was literally
has taken on a life of their own I know
I don't like I think like I don't even
associate with turdy Lou anymore like
she was larger than life she performed
on the main stage kind of like your
stage name
and then you can go home and meet
Claudia
no I was literally I think it's a good
protective barrier so that you can keep
your peace it's like my hat in Montana
the world knows you as turdy Lou yeah
but only the select few know you as
Claudia yesterday I was dming with um
Raising Canes the fast food chain and
they were like Charlie Lou
I was like what no there's Twisters
everywhere that's so crazy especially
since it's such a recent development
like I understand people reaching out
snitch snitch snitch snitch
Turtles but you've always wanted a
nickname I've always wanted a nickname
good because it's the one you got and
you know what I don't hate it it's and
maybe it was like catching on so hard at
Stage Coach because Trinity Lou has like
a southern twig yeah
so maybe that's why maybe it was just
really it was the best weekend ever like
I have watched my own tick tocks 47 000
times and I just I have like so many
drafts that I've just like posted the
thing about tick tocks that I enjoy is I
feel like sometimes they're either way
too short or way too long it's never the
right length well the ones that are like
too short or the perfect one because
they leave people wanting more and you
watch it like day two you guys are
making short ones yeah and I was like I
need more of these outfits yeah and then
day three made a really long one I was
like I wish I had that on day two not to
be like that girl but like all my
outfits are linked on my like to know I
like because everyone was just like
turdy where's that from Dirty where's
that from no I just wanted to I wanted
to see you girls up there shading your
things we were shaking our things yeah
she thinks the worship again and I was
enjoying I meant so I think everyone was
like you guys really shook us to the
core thank you and I literally am home
for three days before we head to
Nashville this weekend Jax isn't coming
anymore which is just absolutely [__]
devastating but we understand you got to
take it easy
um and like the way I'm like this is
gonna be the craziest thing I've ever
said and it's only temporarily true like
the way I don't want to go to Taylor
like I'm not okay like I need to stay
home do you hear my voice like I need to
relax so I need to just like take it
easy for these next three days because I
leave on the Thursday to see Taylor
Swift era's Tori Nashville I'm like I'm
so excited of course three days is a
perfect amount of time you're gonna take
it easy and you'll be ready to go you'll
be fine no and then like I get home
Sunday and then I leave again next week
to go to Dallas for the Academy of
Country Music Awards I'm kind of like
the bell of the South
yeah you should move I'm so down if
there was one Jew I would go you could
be the one
but would it be enough Diana you could
be the first you could inspire a
generation of Jews kind of like Joseph
Smith I'm like the Joseph Smith of my
generation of Jews yeah yeah you could
be Coulda Woulda Shoulda
Coulda Woulda should have
um what do you think the surprise songs
are gonna be in Nashville for Taylor I
have no [__] clue I am now on like
Taylor Instagram reels wow it's finally
hit the reels no and I it's funny like
when you've just watched something once
and then you get served it all the time
so I get all these tailors it was so
toxic the algorithm yeah and
I don't know what the like there's no
way what are real what what our main
songs what are oh oh you don't know I
don't know what the setlist is so like
oh she played this tonight so I don't
know I'm not educated enough I thought
you were gonna say like you know I don't
I'm not educated enough to like guess
what the surprise songs will be but
there's no Rhyme or Reason the only way
I think in Nashville she'll play Tim
McGraw she already did it I think she'll
do it again
I don't think so okay what do you think
I don't know like I don't know like the
only thing people were able to
accurately guess
from the entire era store was this past
weekend she played High infidelity
because the show was on April 29th and
the lyric is do you really want to know
where I was April 29th so I'm going may
6. I don't think there's a song with May
6 in it you know maybe she'll sing Happy
Birthday to the snatcher yeah so it's
also the Snapchat's birthday it's gonna
be a wild weekend like I just I need to
conserve my energy I need to conserve my
social battery
you need to recharge
Turtle her batteries kind of low she's
running on low she always is
so [__] true she stays on low she
stays on low she really does but she
does the most on low it on low battery
yeah like I'm constantly on
um low battery mode my battery is always
yellow your battery
um so we've got a great show because
also the Met Gala was last night no
we're gonna go through everything all
the loops all the stories there's a lot
of like good gossip coming out of it but
I wanted to ask you and just like the
people if it was like a me experience or
you experience like I was on the plane
and I Was Defeated and like I was just
thinking about myself and my Stagecoach
weekend so like the McDonald's like
wasn't like giving like top of mind to
energy so was that just for me or was
that like the vibe the opposite
experience because I feel like for the
like the last few shows I keep being
like the mechal is coming up the mecca
is coming up also because I did just
watch Kardashians where they were hyping
it up so much so it made me excited and
I thought the theme this year was going
to be really exciting because it's Carl
and there's so much to pull from and
really like you don't want Carl rolling
over in his grave over your look like I
feel like people really felt the
pressure like there wasn't anyone in
past years there's no one to be held
accountable to yeah like in this Mecca
like you're accountable to the Legacy to
Carl's Legacy yeah so I just had really
high hopes and you know I I was free
last night so I turned on the red carpet
and I was where did you watch I watched
on Ian it was a really Dreadful
experience you should have went to like
vogue.com I think that's I want to touch
on the television I know I know but they
have it so that like unless you're
vogue.com you're like on the carpets
like literally scratching at people to
get interviews whereas if it wasn't even
about the interviews that were bad
actually the e-correspondent on the
carpet I don't know his name but I
thought he had really fun interviews for
the ones that he got like he was really
knowledgeable and not socially awkward
and just like could make conversation so
tough 10 out of 10. no it was like the
panel and their commentary and then they
would spend so long on one person and
it's like there's hundreds of Subs here
like I saw Kim's here already like show
us right no they're like not keeping up
with social media move on to the next
person yeah so it wasn't a pleasant
experience but I did get to between that
and like looking on Instagram I saw all
the looks and that was good so I had a
fun experience watching and it felt like
a big deal to me because I made it a big
deal and I feel like you overwhelmingly
like were not impressed with this year's
looks I feel like it's the best red
carpet we've seen on the Met Gala in
years yeah no I was like since like
Heavenly Bodies Heavenly Bodies was so
good
um I liked the theme the concept
I you like the beat I like the beat a
lot
um yeah I don't know I was just like
watching things and everyone was just
like it's just everyone is like so
beautiful and has like unlimited access
to the world's best everything and some
of these people I'm like that's what
you're wearing you know yeah maybe it's
at the high bar because like I'm wearing
you know leggings today and the bar
sweatshirt like I understand fashion you
know and I set the bar for these people
and
I set the bar I'll be curious to hear
which people you felt that way about
because I felt like more than ever
before I had like if I'm reading on like
a five star scale five being like
changed my life there were so many fours
okay that's good I just have to say like
I was really feeling like meh about
everything until Anne Hathaway showed up
and Anne Hathaway I don't know like what
happened in her life that like two years
ago she decided she was gonna become
like an IT girl of fashion after being
like America's most hated [__] but I
don't know who made it possible and like
what happened it is like the greatest
thing to ever happen and I just want to
say like never thought I'd say those
words like Anne Hathaway saved the day
yeah she was amongst the top yeah so
we're gonna get into all the looks we're
gonna go through the vogue.com articles
of course you know we are a legal
reputable establishment here so if
you're watching on YouTube it did sound
that you said it sounded like you said
illegal no we are a space legal comma
reputable media brand therefore we
cannot use copyrighted photos that we do
not own that intellectual property you
so we're going to go through this work
article we'll put it in the description
of the podcast in the YouTube so you can
scroll along with us we're not going to
go through every single person because
people listen as a podcast so it would
be frustrating if we had the pictures up
and we were just pointing to stuff and
they put it so we have to use our words
to describe what we're seeing one more
thing I wanted to say about the mechelle
and why I felt underwhelmed
um was it just me or did it feel like
there weren't that many
um
like
it was very A-list and very upper
echelon and I think like this year
really felt like Anna was being like
really strict because there was like no
influencers I like that like when
Charlie and Dixie went like I caught or
just Dixie sorry iconic like Alex Earl
should have been at the Met Gala like
sorry I said what I said you don't like
it not my problem and it just felt like
there were no like like moments in terms
of like honestly where were Kelsey
ballerini and Chase Stokes like of the
moment people it was very like fashion
art A-list and like I get it but that's
but there was also a lot of like you got
invited no there was there was a lot of
people sorry who are you and I feel like
sometimes it's like you get invited once
and then like you keep going back year
after year and it's like well you're not
really relevant right like no I know
like I have a lot I have some hot takes
I just I don't really understand who is
supposed to be invited to the Met Gala
because honestly it feels different
every year and this year felt very like
exclusive art fashion High Society like
I didn't know half the people on the
carpet oh I didn't feel that way but I
agree there were less of like you know
remember when James Charles went like
there weren't like moments like that
like I can't believe this person is
invited but then sometimes it's like
when YouTube had a table I think it was
like a year or two ago I was like okay
like yeah no I I don't
it depends on the people like when
Jackie Aina went I was like yes ma'am
here for it when Dixie went I was like
yes ma'am James Charles I was like okay
like we don't have to we should be
checking it too far but he was the first
like he went before yeah you know I'm
just talking about like individually
like which P some people rub me the
wrong way and some people I'm like yeah
I mean that's how I feel about
everything like every outfit it's like I
don't like it but if you had put it on
Kendall Jenner I would have liked it
she's honestly people say what you want
about Kendall like I don't think there
has ever been a Met Gala where she
wasn't in a top five look no she's
always at a top five looking what's
crazy she's not even my favorite
celebrity or Kardashian I I like I
passively enjoy her but like
when it comes to the mecca like she's my
number one like and I try and when I'm
judging someone's look I try to think if
Kendall wore it would I like it yeah you
know and Kendall's off and I'm like if
someone else wore it would I still like
it no I just like it because it's on
Kendall but I think that's why like she
is a supermodel and like that's why
models are models they wear the clothes
better than anyone else no it's so true
because like even her outfit last night
was literally top five but like I could
see someone else like this looks so
stupid it went out without pants to the
Met Gala No totally
um so we're gonna dive into it all it's
gonna be a great first Tuesday in May
and happy May everyone happy May without
further Ado here are the past five
stories that you need to know and
today's episode is brought to you by
thuma
introducing the bed by thuma handcrafted
from eco-friendly high quality upcycled
wood the bed has a modern minimalist
design that helps Elevate any space it's
super supportive for your mattress it's
breathable and it's made to naturally
minimize noise and create space the bed
is put together using the Timeless
technique of Japanese joinery each piece
locks into place meaning no tools or
excess Hardware is required for assembly
so with clean lines subtle curves and
lifestyle enhancing details the bed is
simple sophistication for the bedroom
now Jackie has a thumba
bed in her house tell me about the
assembly experience because one thing
about us like Australia girls like we're
not going to assemble Furniture no we're
not and if we are it's going to be thuma
because especially if you're assembling
with someone else and you don't want to
get into an error terrible fight Zuma's
there for you honestly I think marriage
counselors should know about them I
agree I can recommend it to anyone
moving in together buying new furniture
because the way that you set it up makes
it so easy hassle-free fight free and
it's also a great gorgeous looking bed
that's comfortable and it's backed with
a lifetime warranty it ships right to
your door and it comes in three easy to
maneuver boxes takes about five minutes
to set up they have a new solid wood
headboard and the original pillow board
so create that feeling of checking into
your favorite boutique hotel suite but
at home with the bed by thuma that is
what it looks like yeah and now go to
thuma.co toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental US go
to thuma.co toast that's t-h-u-m-a dot c
o slash toast for 25 credit today's
episode is also brought to you by bowl
and Branch wake up feeling rested and
refreshed with the softest most
luxurious sheets from Bowling Branch
Bolin branch is the betting expert they
make the highest quality sheets with
Incredible craftsmanship each sheet is
slowly made for an unmatched softness
with 100 and traceable organic cotton
that gets softer with every wash I mean
this is what I look like after not being
in a bowling Branch bed for the last
three days I look not okay it shows I
look not okay
all of our sheets literally are all of
our sisters but Jackie's entire house my
entire house are bedding our bed
accessories I've got throw blankets I've
got the white blanket don't sleep on it
everything that bowling branch makes is
superior it is stunning it is
comfortable it's breathable it's the
best material year round it keeps you
cool it keeps you warm whatever you need
like they just know you know
the signature hem sheets from Bowling
Branch are a bestseller for a reason
they use the highest quality 100 or cut
organic cotton threads on Earth each
sheet set is slowly made for Superior
softness they have over 10 000 rave
reviews and they've even been loved by
four US presidents
they come in 10 versatile colors in all
sizes so that's for beds from Twin up to
California king and it's designed to
feel incredible for all sleepers it's
made without toxins free from synthetic
pesticides formaldehyde and other harsh
chemicals and best of all bowling Branch
gives you a 30 night risk-free guarantee
with free shipping and Returns on all
U.S orders sleep better at night with
bowling Branch get 15 off your first
order when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusion Supply Seaside for
details literally every person in my
life texts me they're like is bowling
Branch like really that [__] I'm like
yes [__] use Koto it's like that just
happened to me yeah love thank you so
much
you're welcome okay let's get into the
looks we're going from vogue.com's
article Roundup of looks they're not the
order that we all experience them in
right which is really hard for me to
wrap my brain around I know and their
first picture is the person who arrived
last and they're also not in any level
of importance or like good to bad right
so we're just we're we're weighing in it
a little bit of a level of importance
which is actually good for our yes for
our sakes yeah so Rihanna up first she
showed up so late everyone was just like
where is this [__] at where's this
[__] at the live streams were over oh
they were yeah that's like so annoying I
know but they did that last time too
yeah the ground I just give a [__] like
she'll get there when she gets there
yeah it must be so nice to not have to
like Quake over anything like everyone
will wait for you no and like I think
people arrive on the red carpet and like
she still hasn't started her hair and
makeup you know like the first people
get there yeah and she's just on her own
timeline she was wearing Valentino it
was like a two-part look so first she
had like the the headpiece the flower
jacket Camellia headpiece which I love
me too and then it also it turned into
like a shrub and then it turned into a
shrug it was very cute I loved it I
understood it you know yeah a lot of
this if I say I don't like something
partially it's like don't understand it
but that's why I liked this theme it was
so easy to understand like there were so
many motifs that you could take of
Carl's like you know the Chanel Tweed
right the Camellia there's like a lot of
different eras he also did like the
Fendi era the Chloe era right but then
there were some dresses that were Carl
inspired from like the 80s or the 90s
that that I didn't know were like Carl
Vibes but then seeing it against the The
Muse The Muse I was like oh Perfection
I'm not crazy about ASAP Rocky's like
Kilt and Jean moment but like it's so
like not about him it doesn't even
matter agree supportive King you know
agreed she looked fabulous I loved I
loved love next up is cardi B
um I was obsessed with this look like
cardi B's so she's so beautiful and like
this is so different than really
anything she ever wears and I thought
she looked great yeah I mean she does
look great and it's very Chanel theme is
five out of five
um it looks great on her and I guess
she's giving us like a little female
Carl yeah
I just loved it and I I was gathering
that in order to be in theme just
wearing black and white we'll do that
there's a lot of black and white and so
it was that the Chanel chameleons I
thought this was like literally gorgeous
like I loved I think she looks great I
think she looks great
um but it doesn't like tickle it doesn't
itch the thing in my in your brain that
it's like I'm obsessed with that's just
a matter of personal taste but she looks
great and on theme and lovely agreed
Jenna Ortega Jenna Ortega's wearing Tom
Brown I think she looks amazing and
perfect and I think Tom Brown like every
time someone wears something that I hate
it's always Tom Brown like Courtney and
Travis last year
um so it's nice to see Tom Brown like
killing it I love this by the way like
it's so it's Chanel like the Tweed the
chain but it's also giving like Marie
Antoinette silhouette she looks great
one thing about me is like every time I
see something Jenna or take like an
interview like she seems so [__] rude
have you like seen I've seen there's
there's like articles that she's rude
and that she what is that I don't know
so I'm trying to separate the art from
the artist here because like I'm like
girl I'll be nice yeah be grateful
she's just giving like honestly bratty
energy maybe it's just like I don't get
her personality maybe that's it yeah
because she might have like a dark sense
of humor right like Wednesday there were
like articles that she was like tough to
work with on set and [__] like that and
then she did a um an interview she did
armchair expert a podcast where she was
talking about how like she literally
went into the writer's room and like
rewrote as she wrote Wednesday and it's
like okay she was just like I just I and
I don't follow her so the only things I
see about her are against my will and
maybe they're just like you know
misquoting her or taking things out of
context but I'm just like okay she's
kind of ready I only watched half of the
first episode
but I feel like this this
reputation that she has actually doesn't
harm her career because it's kind of in
line with the character right a dark
energy yeah yeah and like she talks like
Wednesday talks she's kind of like
method acting so she can get away with
it it's actually like a fair point you
know but if you were playing like you
know in a sweet angel and then we found
out that she's the devil and then
everyone be like this Jenna right right
Jenna's just Wednesday so method yeah
that's a good point okay next Pedro
Pascal and Valentino I have a really
hard time judging men's looks because
for me I'll always be good in a suit and
tie same always will work for me I'll
say this it's a lot of red yeah I don't
get it but I don't get men's fashion and
I'm Happy to Skip Happy to Skip most of
the men unless someone made an impact
yeah I think the best dressed man man
was Bad Bunny like yes I love all white
I love a train like who knew a man scarf
train like lived for it best dressed for
men for me yeah probably we'll keep
going though I also like Jared Leto as
shoe pet even though I'd rather see Brew
pet up there shaking that thing I have a
hot take I think Jared Leto looked
incredibly [__] stupid as the cat
yeah someone had to do it Doja cat did
and that was like in a really cool way
two people did it no his was just like
stupid I feel like he's always just like
doing the most somebody posted in toast
after dark the best Call of all time I
saw Jared Leto is Tom Sandoval like
doing the most and thinking like haha
look at me like shut up I'm just in a
mood today I'm sorry I got off I don't
have beef with Jared Leto like that I do
I do I thought like shoe pet in when
that cat mascot came on the carpet I
thought it was like gay shark like
someone you know Vogue intern wearing it
it would have been better that way and
like if shoe pet was like photo bombing
stuff it's weird that he committed in
such a way yeah
um but I was glad that that someone did
it agreed so it didn't bother me agreed
next
next we have Gigi Hadid ingvanche I'm
sorry like this is so stunning her hair
and makeup is
perfect like this body it's just it's
like actually offensive to like to look
at it I love like I love love love she
always likes slays she never looks like
the best ever and she never looks the
worst she's always like Middle top
middle top and Always In theme yeah I'm
sure because everyone wants to dress her
I know it's probably like easy who
should I go with this year like it's
Fielding offers left right and Center
she looks gorgeous yeah next Kendall
Jenner in Marc Jacobs oh this was Marc
Jacobs so Random
wait this is weird Kendall Jenner and
Marc Jacobs and Wilford tights yeah that
is weird because they were like nude
pantyhose well the brand probably like
was involved like donated money in some
way and I have to say I was looking at
her legs like damn is she wearing tights
I need those tights so honestly you guys
nude pantyhose don't sleep on them no
people do nice looking lag you don't
have to shave if you don't want to you
don't have to worry about like you know
sometimes I get really bad I get purple
yeah no like a blotchy spray tan too no
I'm telling you guys bring back nude
tights wow I'm like looking at this
outfit so differently now knowing it was
Marc Jacobs I just assumed it was like
Versace because she's wearing the big
boots that everyone's wearing
um and all the Versace girls were
wearing like big clunky platforms so I
just assumed that was it and it doesn't
change the way I feel I mean it's it's
so cool it's so cool she looks amazing
and like she's one of my top people I
just have to ask myself if someone else
wore this like what I would say about
them and I don't think I would say all
the things that I'm saying right now I
agree from certain angles from the side
I actually really did not like the shoes
they were like too big but from this
floor they're very like dolls yeah
it's giving like um
emo what's that Festival
that everyone goes to where to listen to
like Fall Out Boy
emo Fest like back in the day uh Warped
Tour yes it's getting Warped Tour okay
from certain angles in this photo when
you can't see them from the side I do
like them
but yes some of it is like a little too
a little too you know yeah no but I
think she looks great
Perfection car would have loved Carl
would have loved the Bell sleeve I love
the legs for days someone tall needed to
wear this yeah and she was the perfect
person and it's it's perfect I love the
collar oh also people are saying it's
giving you got Christ do you know what
that means no so there was this trend on
Tick Tock where people would like prank
everyone and be like
oh my God
Anna Wintour fell down the steps like
something crazy and people be like oh my
God and before the video ended it'd be
like you just got chrised and it would
be a picture of Kris Jenner from the
memory they used to make um
music videos on their family vacations
she's wearing the glittery uh she's
wearing this a shirt that has like a
bedazzled collar and people are saying
it's giving you got Chris if you know
you know so Niche okay next we have Kim
Kardashian and Shia Pirelli so
it probably is I have such a hot take I
[__] hate this look everything about
it no it could have been fixed if she
ripped off that necklace like it's too
much what's with the undergarments on
the side like giving I I hate this look
I just really am confused by the the
shapewear thing like this
um the high undies like it's distracting
I also like why was she wearing a jacket
though I wish she'd put the jacket down
for a second you know what I actually
think the jacket is beautiful if they
have the jacket is beautiful but a lot
of people they wear the jacket on the
bottom steps then they drape it on the
second steps then they put it down on
the third steps like and she's just like
clinging to that jacket for dear life I
want to see the rest of the dress I hate
this like I can't get over it what is
with the neck
the neck didn't bother me so much I
think I think it had the potential to be
like 10 out of 10 but just there's
something about it you know what it's
kind of reminded me of Courtney's Tom
Brown dress with the Gauzy middle yeah
yeah ace bandage middle like At first I
was trying to like look into it and be
like you know what is Kim trying to say
here she's the queen of shapewear she's
giving skims like but you know what I
just think it's a bad dress like and I
think I'm just gonna chalk it up to that
like I do not like this at all like if
the beating had gone over the whole the
whole dress and she took the necklace
off and maybe had the coat on and then
off and got her hair out of her face
like it's just a lot yeah I'm not I
don't like it I like it I don't love it
and she's another one that like
everything that she wears I'm gonna lean
towards liking it yeah because I like
her and so I was just like
it doesn't seem so cohesive for me yeah
but she looks beautiful I hope she was
like more comfortable than she usually
is so true and I hope she had like a
more pleasant getting ready experience
because it wasn't so like some
celebrities literally like trained for
the Met gal like last year she literally
trained for the McAllister she was a new
glare one two days do bleaching her hair
like literally it takes a week usually
for her to go from brunette to blonde
they did it in three days like I don't
think she slept it was like crazy and
then the new glare corset where she had
to like literally rearrange her bones
right and then there are celebrities who
just like literally roll out of bed they
sit in the makeup chair and they show up
at the Red Carpet and like that's
Pleasant that's okay and I just hope she
can like one day have just a fun
experience I feel like this was better
and she was with North yeah both Kylie
and Kim walked out with the kids stormy
and North and then left him in the car
but did they come into the event
I feel like you have to be 21 to be in
the event that's why Charlie demilio
couldn't go and just Dixie went or you
have to be 18 something like that so
maybe they were in the car for fun
that's like a fun car ride yeah I hope
they left the air conditioning on yeah
no yesterday was like a nice day it was
just it was weird with the kids like
yeah I didn't get it let's do Kylie just
to round out the sisters because it was
just the three sisters this year
Christmas
always goes with Tommy Hilfiger I don't
know that was like that wasn't okay and
I feel like Courtney and Chloe could
have gone if they wanted to but didn't
care enough to go yeah I feel like Chloe
had a bad time last year and Courtney
doesn't give a [__] yeah
but it was weird not to see Chris yeah
like if anything like even before Kim
always goes Kendall always goes and even
before Kylie Chris always goes yeah
confusing Kylie's look was really pretty
I don't understand how it was thematic
maybe it was and somebody can't explain
it to me it was just a really like
stunning dress but she looked beautiful
and have you seen that interview of her
that quote of hers that's like going
around someone interviewed them at the
top of the carpet and she was just
talking about how she's like ready to
have fun inside drink some tequila yeah
and I feel like she's like cruising yeah
her boyfriend was Timothy Shamil Lemay
there I don't think so oh because she
was acting like like she was just
feeling single right she's like ready to
go anything to that effect but that was
the vibe I was getting like she wanted
single energy eligible men I love that
for her I think that's an extremely good
place to meet someone if you're Kylie
yeah yeah I loved how Kylie looked I'm
in my Kylie era she could do no wrong I
agree I don't understand how it was on
theme I'm sure in some way that it was
I'm sure it referenced some look from
the 80s that I don't know that the
jacket turned into the cape and she
looked beautiful and was feeling herself
it was and her hair and makeup were
perfect and also when someone is feeling
themself you can tell and it changes how
they look maybe that's what Kendall
always looks good because she's just
like always feeling herself because
she's a model but in some of the red
carpet footage they show you the person
posing and like they fix a little this
and you can tell they're like a little
uncomfortable and which I mean most
people would be it's a lot of pressure
but when someone's just like
effortlessly like here I am I feel
beautiful I don't give a [__] it is you
can tell yeah no Kylie was feeling
herself I completely agree next Anne
Hathaway in Versace Perfection
Perfection like I knew immediately how
it was on theme it was who was it
Versace Versace so it looks like
immediately how it's Versace yeah
because like the clips it was like a
perfect collab of like Chanel Vibes her
hair is perfect she's such a queen like
I can't get over it yeah winner winner
chicken dinner agreed there's not much
else to say there's not much else to say
the gloves that are like ripped off
sleeves it's just perfect yeah I love
her not crazy about the necklace but
like I don't want a nitpick you're very
anti-neckless yeah because it's just
like sometimes like it's okay to take
something off you know yeah
you know isn't that what Coco Chanel
herself said yeah like take that take
off the less dumb thing you put on
before you leave the house that was
literally me at Stagecoach I like had a
hat a necklace a bandana and like a
Bejeweled in my hair and Shannon was
like take the [__] hat off 100 just
take something off I texted snitch day
two I was like take the hat off yeah
the Hat was good day one but you don't
need to wear a hat every day agreed like
then you just miss his hat you're right
but speaking of hats Jennifer Lopez and
Ralph Lauren she went with Val friend
there before and it was a hat situation
again because I remember I said she wore
that like western dress with a cowboy
hat yeah and I said she should have
taken the hat off so the thing with this
is like I don't have one valid critique
there's nothing wrong with it
but it's so like
I don't know this is what I was saying
before like these are just like really
rich perfect like stunning beautiful
people who have access to the best of
everything like yeah this is the best
hair this is the best makeup this is the
best dress and it's like what if Kendall
were wearing it
dying
I don't know it's just like I feel like
this is what JLo always wears like a
sexy gown you know yeah it's like
unoriginal to me but then if you changed
it up I would have been like just go
back to a sexy gown yeah I don't know I
just I I can't critique this in any
other way then yeah
and the hat is not bothering me as much
as it's bothering you no it's not
bothering me and I feel like if she took
the hat off it wouldn't be enough of a
costume look yeah it's just like Yeah
and I don't like love
I don't love when a dress top is like a
bathing suit I agree it's takio put
clothes on I agree and I would say that
to anyone like yeah and like yeah no
it's gibbage was wearing this dress I'd
say like stop with the bathing suit top
no it's giving like that brand that
everywhere it's like 437 swim or
whatever yeah where the tits just like
hang out they're just like that they're
only being supported by a piece of rope
I agree I don't like that that halter
Vibe agree okay Doja cat Perfection yeah
like literal Perfection she's wearing
right now the right person I don't think
everyone could pull this off if everyone
showed up like if other people had
showed up like a cat with the Cindy Lou
Who prosthetic nose it's perfect Kendall
could have showed up like a cat yes yes
and so could Doja I really really do
like it and you have to remember like
this is it's a costume Institute so when
someone I feel like it could go either
way and someone gets too costumey and
it's a joke and it's terrible but when
you do it right it's really awesome no
it this is perfect like I don't have one
complaint I agree it's really stunning I
agree
now
Salma Hayek I didn't see her until now
Salma Hayek is married to the man who
owns every brand at the Salma Hayek's
husband
funds the Met Gala he owns Gucci he owns
everything
so therefore she has access to whatever
she wants and this is just horrible it's
horrible for someone with the access
it's horrible for someone without the
access this
is terrible
yeah I would say it's not great
especially with the access given the
access given what we know yeah it's even
worse yeah and because she's like a
beautiful woman who will look beautiful
in anything yeah but not this like if
Kendall wore it still I think I would
hate it I would have questions I would
question it even if I was questioning it
with Kendall
okay Lil Nas X and Dior what's Dior like
he's not wearing any clothes undies the
undies are Dior I mean the makeup is
gorgeous
I don't um I kind of get it I guess it's
on theme it's costuming
it's not my favorite yeah
yeah it's just it's it's nice to look at
yeah cool it's cool it's cool oh and
Kylie was wearing
um John Paul and she's like the new face
she's a new face I always confuse him
with John Galliano Jackie me [__] too
because it's like there's two there's
two jobs there's two John's in fashion
and one of them is like a Hitler loving
Nazi and the other is just like a nice
guy trying to do his job I'm sure he's
problematic too but whenever I see
Jean-Paul Gaultier I'm like this [__]
is not wearing John [__]
Galliano right now I know I have to like
go through my head I'm like no Derek
Jackie there's another job put it
together I'm so good Jackie it could be
the same thing you like the beat just
hang on
next Aubry Plaza and Stella McCartney I
the look is um is fine we need to talk
about Chloe feynman's interview okay I
just want to say I think this look is
like so basic and ugly like I don't like
it no no I don't like it either I'm not
here to talk about the look I'm tired to
talk about the moment's going viral with
Aubry Plaza and Chloe Fineman Stella
McCartney Madeline Klein okay so I feel
like a lot of people
I feel like other people are
misunderstanding it like literally three
weeks ago Aubry Plaza hosted SNL with
Chloe Feynman Cliff I'm in like
obviously knows her name I feel like
they're friends and she was like and
you're like Audrey what like I felt like
it was a joke and then maybe even like
Stella was joking too like I don't know
I didn't feel like like I wasn't I
thought it was a joke because like you
know these like Chloe fireman Aubrey
positive like such weird senses of humor
like yeah I personally don't understand
yeah I feel like it was a joke okay I
could say that maybe
Audrey who is a joke because they
probably know each other but cell
McCartney telling Chloe five and she's
not taking it seriously was not a joke
yeah did you feel like maybe um Chloe
Foundry was drunk
no I just think she was not the right
person for the job yeah also totally
random but I found out like I was
shocking like I was doing some Recon on
Tick Tock this morning did you know
Chloe feynman's a Scientologist no I
didn't know that is that just
interesting that is it's because she's
like newly famous and I feel like
I don't know I just found that
surprising and she's in New York I
didn't know they have a big you know
Outreach here yes it's in Times Square
big ass thing I just went to an event
that was like right next door I was like
damn it's on like like by all the
Broadway theaters it looks like a
Broadway Theater I think it was a really
weird moment yeah I mean this is just an
ongoing conversation we're having about
like what what are we saying maketh a
host what make it the host I think like
Vogue has really
um
invested in Emma Chamberlain and I think
her red carpet interviews are very good
and I think that's an example of like an
influencer celebrity thriving in a
position where they're being given an
opportunity to host but I don't think
that's working for everyone
um and I don't think it was working for
Chloe Feynman and and I think people are
like oh she's funny like she can do it
but
no like no because no because I don't
mean the host to be like really funny
because it's not about you exactly like
it's good if you are funny and then you
know when you have your moments you have
your moments but like I don't need a
comedian yep hosting yeah I don't know I
just I think we're in this weird place
now where like everyone is starting to
like really point out how all these
celebrities such influential people
becoming hosts it's like not working out
anymore like we took it too far we took
it one step too far and I feel like now
everyone's noticing it and that's why
like those clips of like Chloe are going
viral yeah like these little awkward
moments that maybe no one would have
really picked up on but now it's like
well what are we doing yeah what are we
doing no and especially for this event
like there's so much knowledge that you
have to have about the theme fashion and
the exhibit and the celebrities and just
the history and you need a professional
yeah agreed and like Chloe Feynman has a
different job but she's very good at
right I will say I do think LaLa Anthony
is another one of those people who
is doing a good job that's because she
has a background in hosting she actually
is a professional host and she's like
low-key friends with everyone like every
person there has a story they want to
tell they're like oh I saw you last week
like she's really good she's good and
I'm glad they used her again like they
they worked out last year and they're
doing it again yeah
Bad Bunny in giacomas
dated and his girlfriend Miss Kenny was
there they were like seen together and
they're staying together all week like
they're so cute they're so together and
they're a good looking couple like I'm
here for it yeah agreed Billy eilish
cute
yeah she looks very Billy and also very
met she looks very Billy
I think it really works for her yeah
uh oh I didn't see Olivia Rodrigo before
and Tom Brown it's cute it's very Chanel
I hate the hair oh my God I don't like
it okay I don't like it she doesn't like
it oh Bradley Cooper was there just
wearing a black house
hot he looks great that's my favorite
man literally doing the least and also
doing the most yeah and he's wearing
sunglasses that are okay they're like
Aviator shaped yeah but they're a little
weird
um now surprisingly I think one of the
worst stressed people ever was Gisele
giving season one Real Housewife at her
reunion doing the most hate hate hate
okay I think she it's not my favorite I
wish we could have seen by the way sorry
she's in Chanel I wish we could have
seen the dress without the cape for one
second yeah the cape would be dropped
but I did see an old photo like she
modeled this dress when it came out so
that's cool still I looked like glowing
and like she's having fun but um
I didn't love this dress on her maybe on
Kendall no not on Kendall I wouldn't
have loved it on Kendall either it's
almost like a little too covered up no I
don't I literally just there's nothing I
like about this yeah like if Kris Jenner
went she could wear it it's perfect for
an older woman I completely I mean I
guess Giselle isn't a wonderful woman I
like why she's wearing no no it's
terrible yeah next we have Priyanka
Chopra Jonas and Nick Jonas and I think
they just look stupid like I'm well I'm
like really feeling like in a bad mood
I'm sorry I just feel like they look
silly I don't think they look stupid
because I think they look normal and
fine and they didn't like do anything
creative maybe it's just like this is a
bad picture but they look like so
like not in sync does that make sense
yeah that does make sense like I think
they just did her dirty with this photo
like her leg is not fully popped and I
don't know I just don't I don't like it
I don't think there's anything to
dislike and I don't think there's
anything to like
that's how I feel and honestly like he
looks like her son in this photo
like the way he's like holding on to her
and like it's so much shorter than he's
like Mommy like it's giving Mommy energy
and like not like the sexy like Mommy
Daddy way like just in like
so cute like I brought my son into the
magella yeah which like so did um Kate
Moss she brought her she brought her
daughter yeah next Cara delefe Cara
Delevingne in Carl Lagerfeld there's
like a lot I feel
like pressure for Cara Delevingne to be
like the It Girl of the moment tonight
she was Carl's Muse Carl discovered her
Carl thought she was like the best
greatest thing that ever happened
um and this is cute yeah there's a lot
of pressure she should have been best
dressed and she's not yeah but she looks
good and cool and like and she looks
healthy yeah and I feel like she's doing
really well and I'm happy first so I
don't want to say anything negative yeah
but like I don't want to say anything
negative like this happened sucks it's
not for me but like she has her own
style yes yes very edgy so she she looks
cool I would have preferred to see her
in like classic Chanel
as opposed to like Carl Lagerfeld brand
yeah but some of the classic Chanel
looks like Margot Robbie for example
nothing boring gave nothing I agree next
we have lizzo in Chanel I love by the
way I think this is so cute and so
simple and I love her gloves I think
lizzo looked great I love the hair no
complaints love you like the micro bangs
which is attractive those are micro
bangs you know what they're not
bothering me
usually it's like I didn't even notice
usually it's the first thing I see I'm
like oh micro bangs I hate the whole
look yeah no I I love this I like the
dress a lot I think she's wearing little
booties which I hate but yeah the shoes
are giving
um like Steve Madden energy yeah like
Jeffrey camera we're going to the club
yeah yeah but I'm choosing to look past
it because I think she looks great like
really this is a very very beautiful and
flattering dress I agree
next Nicole Kidman and Keith Urban and
Chanel Nicole Kidman's one of those
people who you were like she just put on
a dress and did her hair and like she
looks pretty I like that he's you know
doing his like English tuxedo thing
these two are so like giving nothing but
giving everything they're great there
has to be like people there who just
like show up and show up in Chanel and
they look beautiful and they are not
like Reinventing the wheel I will say
this like blush moment and then a big
black shoe I hate she should have worn
like a an off-white yeah but I'll live
I'll survive
L Fanning and Vivian Westwood
you know a lot of people were upset
Vivian Westwood was not like the honoree
this year like it should have been her
because she like died
oh I didn't know that or did Caroline
Herrera die no no it was one
um
so I think this is like nice I don't
know I'm just chucking this up to
something I don't understand yeah I'm
sure there's a I'm sure there was a
model who walked in a show who looked
just like this right it's giving Bridal
Couture yeah I don't get it but I
respect it but it also is giving Regina
George yes your neck brace neck brace
with the things on the sides totally
maybe that was the inspo maybe but she's
a cutie and I think it's good to take
chances when you're all fans yeah yeah
it's so easy to take chances when you're
alphanic next as stated previously
Margot Robbie who looks gorgeous
yet boring there's nothing wrong with
this but there's nothing right with it
there's nothing wrong with it there's a
lot right with it like it's a beautiful
dress for an awards show yeah it's on
theme award show she like doesn't slay
red carpets that much she's very basic
no yeah she doesn't have like I feel the
right stylist for her she also is locked
into a Chanel contract like so she
should be best dressed no Chanel red
carpet is like at this oh yes at this
event yes yes yes yes agreed next Emily
Ratajkowski in Tory Burch
she's like she can't look bad in
anything no it's like a pretty dress but
I feel like when you can look bad in
anything like it's also really hard to
look amazing because everyone just says
like oh you just look amazing because
you're Emily radicals like if Kendall
was wearing this yeah I don't know I
might feel a little differently well
it's so important like the litmus test
for today is like but what if Kendall
was wearing no that's what I had to ask
myself all night last night because I
could feel myself being biased I'm like
do I just not like her no I'm so biased
because one thing about me like I'm so
invested in these celebrities lives and
like I [__] hate some of these people
you know so I just hate what they're
wearing yeah so you have to put it on
toxic like I can own that you have to
put it on Kendall yeah next Mindy Kaling
my [__] Queen I love this picture she
looks amazing she looks amazing the
stress is so beautiful dress I'm just
like so annoyed with the way people are
talking about Mindy Kaling these days
like I was telling you I was on Twitter
I was following the entire magella on
Twitter on my phone last night while I
was on the plane and I was seeing looks
and it's like every person had got an
article you know page six like Margot
Robbie stuns in Chanel and so for Mindy
Kaling it's like Mindy Kaling shows off
weight loss it's like okay first of all
she's been this weight now for a long
amount of time like can we move on for a
minute it's like why is it about that
like it's so annoying and it's like
she's been hiding for two years and then
came to the mechality show she goes
everywhere she we saw her last week she
was at the White House like she's
constantly doing things like it's so
[__] annoying like could you talk
about anything else like she's an
accomplished person yeah and she looks
really great she looks amazing she looks
like so happy and healthy and like I
just [__] love her and like canopy
about that no yeah no especially since
like we know this is how she looks now
yeah it's not like some big silly she's
literally been living underground and
then she came out right and then if she
if she had big coat on and she had
mailed at the Mac Outlaw 60 pounds you
could say she showed off her weight loss
so annoying like stop next we have Paris
Hilton in Marc Jacobs with Marc Jacob at
her first ever Mecca I know isn't that
crazy uh it is crazy but since I just
read her book I was thinking about her
recently and I was wondering if she had
ever been and
she had never been but it makes sense
that this year of all the years would be
her first year because she's really like
in her elegant businesswoman era yeah
and she looked beautiful like I love
this the makeup was a little heavy but
like I got it it was a part of the look
yeah she looked gorgeous and she like
looks like she was feeling herself like
on the red carpet she like when you
watch the videos of the photos being
taken like she doesn't look nervous
she's just like yes [__] I am Paris
Hilton I look [__] fabulous like she
was really into it yeah and she's
wearing the big shoes too yes which like
Kendall was wearing but these were the
heel version not boots yeah I like them
next we have Lily Collins
Lily Collins is always like a high class
sleigh and that's what this is It's a
high fashion high class moment and I
would literally never wear this and I
hate the hair but it's perfect for her
it's perfect for her no complaints and
she yeah she just looks right you know
this is a look that like Anna loves and
that's why she keeps getting invited
back she literally is always invited
yeah there are people who are just like
Fast who have a face and a body for
fashion where was Zendaya
no speaking of people who are just like
fashion girls
missing in action hmm
next Michelle yo in Carl Lagerfeld I
love Michelle yeah perfect no complaints
really perfect yep
next one of my favorites and I am every
year Naomi Campbell and Chanel beautiful
I loved this dress when I saw it on
e-red carpet I was glad they were taking
a lot of time with it and telling us
everything about it
um she looks amazing she always looks
amazing and she's another one I'm like
do I like it or do I like it because
it's Naomi Campbell both but it's both
like I think the stress would really
look pretty it's like a it's like an
objectively pretty dress yeah but being
on the Naomi Campbell like does make it
more beautiful but I feel like on
someone else I might be like boring yeah
yeah I also think like the pink is
perfect for her skin tone like I just
think nobody else could have worn this
dress better agreed she likes pink like
actually I think of Kendall Ward I'd be
like this is boring
right damn yeah next we have Emily Blunt
and Michael Kors she looks so Carl
Lagerfeld met theme
right I guess I don't I'm not saying
that it's my favorite I'm just saying
that I know what year it is look I feel
like when we do these Recaps like we get
to a point where we just have to say
like this is an ugly dress you know like
I get it it's fashion objective art okay
this is ugly I don't think it's
ugly
there are things that are ugly I haven't
seen one yet in this street in this
article this isn't ugly it's just like
like this is a young gorgeous woman like
what is she wearing pants I think this
is pants
with a cape behind it like it's hard to
see it's ugly and I said what I said
yeah Emma Chamberlain and Mew Mew
obsessed Beyond obsess the only
complaint I have is like her makeup was
like a little heavy like the eyes were a
little too dark for my taste but she is
she still lays she never [__] misses
a beat and it must be so exciting for
her to like always be able to go first
like I know the mecca has started when
Emma Chamberlain arrives because she's
the right carpet correspondent at the
top so she has to be there first and
she's just become a staple of this event
which is so crazy because unless we not
forgot she's a YouTuber at her core I
love this look and I love Emma
Chamberlain and I'm I'm loving this
journey for her I love it I don't have
one note I think the makeup is perfect
everything gorgeous tailored to
Perfection next we have new mama Kiki
Palmer the way I would take a bullet for
this woman the way she looks so good
when did she give birth a month ago like
she is so sin snatched this dress this
hair this cape I I'm definitely biased
because I love this woman but there's
not a single thing I love that she's not
wearing any jewelry like it's so simple
I'm obsessed obsessed agreed like I I
can't and she spoke to e that I saw um
her interview and she's just having fun
she's like after being a mom that's the
hardest thing this is a breeze 100 so I
think she was having fun mom's night out
and I think whoever did the hair like
deserves an award the hair is perfect
yep next we discussed Jared Leto and
then he had two looks he was the mascot
and then the gothic King he's also
playing Carl in a film oh coming up
which is a good casting okay
so there's information that maybe you
didn't know no I did it and I cleaned
from me right it's important
um
like one thing about me like now I'm
letting my body scan the way like I find
Jared a little Annoying like I'm sorry
right we know we know so I can't really
give like an unbiased critique here oh
okay let's move on to Janelle Monae in
Tom Brown it was very cool moment look
and I loved it it was very very cool it
was super cool it was super coral and
fun and also so her because she does
this a lot like she's always like
monochromatic black and white which is
also very campy where like remember at I
think actual Camp she had like that
dress that had like the blinking eye
yeah yeah yeah yeah I love this yeah I
agree this red carpet theme was made for
her and she crushed I think she was a
big Muse of Carl's too yeah and I feel
like her whole aesthetic is very just
like Carl inspired black and white like
she's so yeah she's so Carl yeah now on
the opposite Spectrum somebody's whose
outfit deserves jail is Mary J Blige yep
I'm shocked like this is actually this
is probably my worst rest which is crazy
because like like the way and if Kendall
wore it if Kendall wore it were stressed
like I and I'm like my bias is so real
and everyone knows like they said I'd
never be a leader
they say I never wear a crown like I
love Mary J Blige and I [__] hate
this yeah it doesn't fit right it's just
ugly
yeah and I'm sure somebody could argue
how it's in theme but it's not giving
theme well the flower the camellia
flower sure
next oh Madeline Klein and Stella
McCartney I saw the interview but I
didn't actually see the look it's really
pretty it's a word show nicely it's a
word show nice looking and this is what
we were saying at the beginning of the
show like people who just were invited
one year and keep getting invited back
like this wasn't a particularly like
dazzling ear for Madeline wasn't that
movie Glass Onion
oh I guess yeah yeah no she was okay
fair I'm just like oh that's like random
it just felt like oh you again yeah like
Lily Reinhardt keeps getting all the
Riverdale people yeah
none of them were there okay I think
they're filming and I think they're
filming yeah
oh another potential best look for me is
Tiana Taylor yeah yeah like this is
really she's so cool and like effortless
and not everyone could pull this off
like honestly I don't even think Kendall
could pull it off like that's this is
really something else Tom Brown like
low-key killing it yeah
that's crazy for you yeah yeah
uh next who do we have
I'm still scrolling me too we don't need
to talk about like some of these
irrelevance yeah agreed
I feel like maybe we went through them
all uh I feel like there were more oh I
actually really liked Amanda Seyfried
even though it's like not even remotely
on theme it's amazing and it's not like
original I feel like this is quite
literally like Taylor's before this
dress yeah and somebody else did this
hair like it's so kind of it's getting
like Basic Energy it's it's wrong
but then I also think it's the wrong
person I agree but it does feel like
Taylor Swift something she would wear
yeah which is a compliment yeah of
course Miranda Kerr looks beautiful oh I
didn't see her is a sleigh and a half
yeah oh my gosh she looks beautiful so
now that we're rounding out like the
people give me your best rest and your
worst dress oh sorry honorable mention
to Nicola Peltz yeah I barely saw her
photo and now I'm just seeing the one
with her in Brooklyn they always look
great and they always look really simple
and they don't do the most no but she's
on theme she looks so I actually I love
what she's wearing I love her hair too I
agree but she's another one like she
could really wear she could do no wrong
anything and you know she just pulled
that necklace out of her mom's closet
and it's like six million dollars yeah
okay so best dress yeah who's your best
friend that is who we've spoken about so
far
Anne Hathaway
is amongst and Hathaway is my best rest
for sure
but I feel like I'm like there were so
many other people
who I liked and the students were
stressed
well someone who's like consistently my
worst dressed is um
what's his name Ben Platt oh okay that's
what you think about he wasn't on that
thing I just maybe I'm biased again
because you were a big Jewish star
necklace I kind of liked it so I didn't
love the outfit when I saw it but then I
saw his red carpet interview with E and
I really liked his interview and he's
just very like succinct and well spoken
he was talking about his new show he was
talking about anti-Semitism and he and
he was like very brief and very powerful
yeah and he and I was like you know what
I'm gonna scale back on my Ben Platt
that's where the bias comes in like I
get it but I feel like he's one of those
people like he goes every year now and
it's like
why actually I disagree
well I don't know if he goes everywhere
I'm saying him being invited this year
like he's in a Broadway production this
is New York Met Gala he's like the talk
of the theater Town kind of how Leah
Michelle was there like I actually think
him being invited is extremely
appropriate what do you think about Leah
Michelle's outfit it was pretty it's
Michael Kors it's very basic she always
does Michael Kors like she's like some
partnership with him the hair was
getting Fanny Bryce it was giving Barbra
Streisand like she's so obvious like I
thought she look great yeah it was cute
it was cute but there were a lot of
people who weren't there okay like who
like Kaya Gerber Yeah Austin Butler I
feel like we didn't have a lot of couple
moments the one couple moment that we
did have was tsuki Waterhouse and Rob
Patton
there red carpet debut as a couple I
didn't know they were stuck together I
don't think they ever broke up like I
thought that he dated FKA twigs after
Suki no
I think like him and tsuki were friends
FKA and then he's been with Suki ever
since not only like have they never
shown up anywhere together they are so
[__] touchy like I was literally
getting like riled up I'm like yes grab
her grab her like I for they both looked
amazing it was amazing and neither one
of them alone I would have remarked on
their outfits together their best dress
she is so lucky like I'm so jealous I
try not to Harbor like a lot of people
Cooper was there and Kristen Stewart I'm
Kristen Stewart people are loving
Kristen Stewart's outfit yeah it's very
she was also one of she's like a big
face to Chanel I think she was like very
um you know Carl was very inspired by
her I personally I would never wear it
but I get that whole like androgynous
like I get it I respect it but it's not
like my favorite yeah um I thought it
looked like Harry Styles and where was
Harry Styles yeah he's on tour yeah but
still like that's what I'm saying like a
lot of people weren't there but it
didn't feel absent of a-listers like
that one year for the first year in a
long time Blake Lively did not go
because she just had a baby yeah no for
sure but she's been like and events so
I'm sure yeah you should go to Tiffany
Haley Bieber yeah Mrs Bieber and Justin
yeah that's a Miss for the community
yeah
and I feel like like two years ago when
they did like that September one
there were a lot of a-listers missing
and I really feel like it was because
you had to be vaccinated and I think a
lot of these Hollywood folks like don't
like you know they're very like green
and they don't put like chemicals in
their bodies or whatever so that I
understood I actually understood that
one was like a free for all the people
who were able to attend right it's like
I got a backs card let me in like it was
very much like the bar was lowered yeah
and now the bar has been raised again
and they're back to like you know being
strict but it did feel like
notable notably people were missing I
mean it's a seventh year in a row we
haven't gotten Taylor like come on [__]
just come like maybe she has an issue
with the event like maybe she had a bad
time but she was like on the board and
it's like a Blake Lively event like it's
always her people also a Kardashian
event I know but it wasn't when she used
to go like remember when Demi Lovato
went and she said she had a terrible
time and she'll never go in like I feel
like that's very real for some people
for sure it must be like so intimidating
like yeah especially if you don't have
your peeps Ben Platt was saying in his
interview who's more excited this year
because his co-star was with him and
he's never really had a buddy in the
event you know that's why it's like the
buddy system is crucial fair to be a
Kardashian like you have like you're not
even a buddy like your sisters that's
how I feel like when I go on influencer
things and like Margo where you get to
go because it's so unfair yeah it's like
a such a leg up yeah
yeah
um okay are you ready for some more Met
Gala news if it's the McAllen news
that's brought to you by stamps.com it
is when every person moment and penny
counts to your business you can't afford
to take any of them for granted and
stamps.com they get it because for the
last 25 years they've been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money so you can focus on your business
knowing stamps.com has all your postage
needs covered with premium discounts and
great rates it's a post office but it's
in your office with stamps.com all you
need is a computer and a printer they
even send you a free scale so you have
everything you need to get started if
you need a package pickup you can easily
schedule it through the stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart so if you have an online
business you have a side hustle
e-commerce stamps.com is a no-brainer
but even for us we're always using
stamps.com we have like a million boxes
coming in and out of here every day
things I need to send to Jackie Studio
Jackie needs to send to me we just are
always doing things and like going to
the post office is really not an ideal
situation but we bring the post office
into our office with stamps.com they
also have premium discounts because
running a business isn't cheap espec
when it comes to tip of failing orders
for your customers luckily stamps.com
has huge carrier discounts up to 84 off
USPS and UPS rates for 25 years
stamps.com has been an indispensable
resource for over a million businesses
get access to the USPS and UPS services
that you need right from your computer
anytime day or night there's no lines no
traffic and no waiting set your business
up for success and get started with
stamps.com today sign up with our promo
code toast for a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts are
required just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code toast that's t-o-a-s-t
today's episode is also brought to you
by liquid death I don't know why I can't
say liquid I have to say liquid death
because that's like the core they're
hardcore
so you've probably seen these tall boy
cans with skulls on them everyone has
been drinking liquid death they are
actually just their new healthy Iced
Teas and they're so good The Taste is
next level
so they have three new T is the armless
Palmer the Grim leafer and the rest in
Peach they look like big old like tall
cans of beer but they're actually just
iced tea they're not alcoholic they are
so good
and their cans of iced tea are healthy
unlike a lot of the other Iced Teas that
are loaded with sugar these ones are
lightly lightly sweetened with 6 grams
of Premium Agave they have only 30
calories and they provide a micro dose
of 30 milligrams of caffeine for each
tall boy they're also enhanced with B
vitamins 30 calories they're really big
like you're getting a big bang for that
30 calories so again the three flavors
are grimly fur rest in Peach and the
armless Hammer I happen to love the rest
in Peach I love a peach
um tea moment I just think it's
delicious I love to drink it in the
morning freak people out when I had a
bunch of gas co-hosts in here I was like
drinking them and they were like oh are
you drinking alcohol I'm like yeah yeah
I am we get crazy here
um so we know and love the liquid death
Waters Sparkling Waters flavored
Sparkling Waters and now their teas are
so good their new iced tea flavors are
available now with free shipping on
Amazon and retailers near you as an
added bonus the toast listeners get 20
off their first liquid death apparel
purchase when you go to liquiddeath.com
toast some exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com t-o-a-s-t
thank you Claudia you're welcome thank
you so much okay our next story Kim
Kardashian and Pete Davidson reunite
quote unquote that's Met Gala nine
months after their breakup the two were
photographed talking inside the event
with Usher and you know Kim's a big
Usher fan she went to his residency two
times in a row
um I feel like the beckell is kind of
this like annual important thing for Kim
and Pete like three years ago was when
they like met and exchanged numbers two
years ago or a year a year ago is when
they like debuted so it's like a thing
for them they appear to be on good terms
everyone is like gagging I actually feel
like
he's in a new relationship she's
literally 20 years older than him like I
don't feel like there's any hard
feelings like it's good it's all good no
but it is it must be a little awkward
they were so serious there are so many
exes I was just scrolling through the
rest of the article and seeing other
people who were there like there was so
like also his other ex Margaret quality
was there looking horrible I'm sorry
she's my worst dressed I take it back
I'm sorry there's no excuse for a young
girl who's been given everything in her
life to show up at the mecca looking
like that in a black nightgown terrible
but I feel like she's the kind of star
who just gets is dressed by a designer
and has no say there's no excuse
FKA twigs was there
and Suki yeah that's definitely awkward
I think the shake was there and Bradley
Cooper and Suki irina's Shake was there
like wearing ballet flats what was that
I don't know but she looked really good
I forget what she was wearing but I
remember enjoying it it was like a white
bridal dress with like ballet slippers I
literally thought she looked horrible
I remember I don't remember I can't
remember call the dress but I remember
liking it this is the thing with the
mechala one like you're May it's like
was the dress horrible or am I just
jealous you know no no no no I I don't
think it's that yeah it was the dress
horrible or is like this person just not
someone who's gonna kiss me yeah that's
true you know like I'm not waiting to
see what they wore that zone impressed
me also Sydney Sweeney we didn't talk
about her oh yeah because the thing is I
have a very high bar for Sydney Sweeney
and she's constantly coming up short
this was fine I don't know who put that
big ugly ass bow in her [__]
hair and put it on incorrectly because
she looked like she was going to school
and she just got married that's what you
have to wear when you go to school you
have to put this like black lace thing
on top of your head it was such an ugly
[__] bow and it bothered me so much
and then it like matched the bow at the
end I didn't like the bow at the bottom
no
it wasn't bad
but and I admittedly have a high bar for
Sydney Sweeney as I should because she's
literally that [__] and she's never
being that [__] like yeah but I feel
like she's another one who it's like
because she's so gorgeous and perfect
the bar is so high and it's like
she could never meet it no she's just
not meeting it she's not meeting it and
she could I for a while she was like
looped into like if she wore what
Kendall wore I wouldn't like it she's
not tall enough okay
for a while like she had this turnt red
carpet energy and it was because she was
in this like wear contract with Tory
Burch and like it was like holding her
back and I believe she's out of it and
she's still so it wasn't Tori I take it
back up for blaming Tori it's better but
it's not where it needs to be no someone
get Maeve in there somebody gets tired
of me maybe there or Danny Michelle
somebody yeah
so Lux Kim and Pete spoke cute like I
feel like there's really no weird blood
there honestly like I feel like it's
okay it was weird they broke up just out
of the blue one day I think he proposed
but okay oh you do like something he did
something weird but he's with Chase sui
now yeah yeah no like they're not
getting back together but like literally
they were head over heels in love with
each other she's talking about having
more kids and then the next day not the
next day but then one day they're just
broken up well we better find out on
Kardashians season two three whatever
I'm real I'm really looking forward to
it yeah uh next we have a lot of bed
news on the carpet Serena Williams
revealed that she's pregnant with baby
number two and Carly Kloss revealed that
she's pregnant with baby number two I
love this like lost drama baby
announcement you know like no gender
reveal just like yeah [__] I'm at the
most fabulous event oh yeah and I'm
pregnant I'm the happiest I've ever been
eat my ass like I love it you know yeah
I thought Carl the closet actually
looked great because you know one thing
about me like I am gonna make that joke
about her she was looking Carl right she
was you know what she looked very good
she was not looking Camp right in the
eye but she was looking Carl right you
know I loved her outfit I love that she
was pregnant I thought she looked
beautiful and like radiant I really
liked it and like I feel like sometimes
you know you would think the bump would
hinder an outfit you know that's how I
feel like no I disagree no no that's no
like you'd rather be if you have a big
event like you'd rather not have a no I
actually disagree I think there's so
many ways to like dress up a bump and
like actually look cuter than you could
have looked not pregnant I feel like
this is an outfit that looks so much
cuter pregnant yeah then if she like
wasn't or someone else wore it so I
loved it me too and I'm so happy for her
and Serena Serena that's really cute
denial for Serene or we are and you know
what the eye says she's pregnant yeah I
loved loved and then of course Rihanna
had her bum moment too when she took off
her code and we'd be known but it was a
big night for the bump it was a big
night for the bump it was nice nice to
see mothers out there doing their thing
we've got you know postpartum girlies
like Keke Palmer we've got partum
girlies does that mean pregnant partum
it should because
what does parda mean such a good
question
meaning I feel like it mean that might
mean the act of like birth so if you're
pregnant like you're not
we're like no one was giving birth on
the carpet so there weren't any partum
girlies I understand now that would be
Camp if somebody just you know rolled
out in a hospital bed pardon means it's
a Latin word it means a bearing or
bringing forth so it's the actual like
pushing right okay so they're not part
of damn well somebody should do that
maybe that should be the theme next year
yeah someone will because everyone's
just trying to constantly do yeah do the
most and like be the most original it's
also so crazy when you watch like the
live stream how like no one can actually
walk in their outfits and like there are
these handlers who literally have to
carry them up the steps but also like
the handlers like you can feel them like
being annoying and the celebrities like
get the [__] out of my picture they're
always in the background you know or
like they're like telling them something
like to move up and if you stop yeah
it's a lot yeah no it's like chaos and
the cool thing about well cool that I
think it's cool but I'm sure the
celebrities hate it is there's really no
hierarchy at the Red Carpet like all the
celebrities they wait in a line to it's
not like oh Kim's here she gets to cut
no it's literally like JLo Waits behind
it's literally total um
egalitarianism
I do think some people get special
treatment last year Kim had they set up
a changing room for her she like went to
the Met Gala in just like a robe
and shapewear because she put on her
dress there because and then at the top
of the steps like Ripley's took it back
so like they gave her something yeah but
for the most part like it's I think
maybe unless you're a host like I think
maybe Blake Lively gets to cut the line
but they get their hosts get there first
yeah yeah no it's just like when you see
behind the scenes like iPhone footage
like on Tick Tock and it's other
celebrities like in a tent waiting in
line to go get their photos taken it's
like it's humbling no but also it's like
maybe like Rihanna can come as late as
she did but if it was someone else they
would have not let them in they were too
late like the carpet does eventually
close well let's also talk about the
cockroach
so on brand like I love love love love
that
um I was gonna make a joke but I can't
um
I love that because this is like New
York's event New York's finest and it
has to be authentic and no and I feel
like you know if you just looked at
these photos and and the med and you
didn't come to New York you would say
wow New York is this like gorgeous
Beacon of Glamor fashion
City
but no but we got roaches we do we have
we have super roaches and the roaches
are the great equalizer like no matter
who you are you know you could be like
you know in the worst neighborhood or at
the Met Gala and there's a [__]
cockroach by your foot did you see the
photographer who tried to kill it and
then it almost crawled to literally up
his pants no oh my God it's horrifying
no it's horrifying that's crazy he was
photographing he was literally like a
Getty Images and he was photographing
the Cockroach he was like this is funny
and then he went to go kill it and he
missed it but he didn't know so it
literally hopped onto his pants no I
know I'm like clenching my ankles just
that's horrible and then like the eggs
and now he's gonna have like a whole
Rich family living in this house I know
people don't realize this you're not
supposed to step on a cockroach yeah
because then they're they're eggs like
get on your foot and then you bring them
into your house yeah so if you do just
throw away the show
I don't know how you're supposed to kill
a cockroach otherwise
oh by the way these cockroaches they
could survive nuclear war they survive
in your Bigfoot like
no they they can't survive a crush no
they can they'll literally start running
again
don't play dead we have to move on okay
we have to move on but best dress for
sure they're cockroach yeah 100 Carl
would have loved Carl would have loved a
little snack for pushette
shoe pet whatever
um that's a mechelle recap like we don't
really have Fast Five today because it's
like we're already at literally an hour
20 minutes and when it was like the fast
drive with Michael I'm excited to see
like some footage from inside After
parties performers Yeah question mark
question mark
so it looks like it looked cool it was
fun it was fun to be a part of it I
thought overwhelmingly everyone looked
really really nice yeah I agree I was
I'm just in a negative mood today I got
like a really dumb place for a while
especially with Camp people didn't know
what to do and then like two American
gilded glamours lexicon oh yeah and
people like did not know what to do so I
feel like this theme was perfect
everyone adhered to it everyone looked
really nice and really elegant and the
Met Gala like feels like a prestigious
event once again yeah
what I'm loving you see the Tweet going
around I think I should you send it to
me uh Carl Lagerfeld you would have
loved those epic oh my God it's so funny
so true so true
um so that's our show that's our recap
Jax such a pleasure to be back with you
like really there aren't there are truly
no words it's a pleasure to be back it's
a what it's a pleasure you know podcast
with you I said Thank you to Olivia
during the episode yesterday and she
goes it's a pleasure but not even
because she listens all the time but
because of Moana is that what it's from
no oh no that's you're welcome the
customer service line it's just a family
joke oh no sorry I was confusing get a
welcome oh that's Maui that's why I
thought she was gonna say it because
Trucker's for Maui because she's like a
mom yeah yeah yeah no no I listened to
your podcast with Olivia it was
hysterical and I loved hearing everyone
talk about me my favorite my favorite
subject yeah and she was just being like
so flattering as was I but she was being
like flattering towards me too which was
so sweet she's such a queen yeah thanks
to everyone who helped us out this last
week
um so the schedule for this week is
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Jackson quad
in studio Friday I will be in Nashville
but we'll be podcasting like audio only
so just no Studio Friday okay great
can't wait does that work for everyone
works for me does it work for everyone
good because it's a wedding bad love you
guys thank you so much for listening to
the testimony Joe wait until the five
stories you need to know everybody on
YouTube watching this on YouTube these
videos
hope you guys have a great day and we'll
see you tomorrow wow tomorrow's ready
hump day bye